Okay, bonjour, je m'appelle Enric, je suis, I'm doing, the walk around the world, and I'm here with Mathieu, Mathieu what else?
Mathieu Lépine.
Lépine, he's running around the world, so I started in Barcelona, he started in Bologna, you said?
Bologna.
Did you pass through Bologna?
No, we've been speaking since then through WhatsApp, because he's faster than me, obviously, because he's running.
So he's explaining to me what's going on here and there, but I took a plane now, one week ago, I took a plane, so of course, now I met him, he's going to surpass me again, but since we are here in Hiba, this is Uzbekistan, I said, okay, let's do an interview.
How many kilometers did you run today?
Today I've run 43 kilometers, or 42, like a marathon today.
In this heat, right?
Actually.
We are here.
Today is 4th of August, and here in Uzbekistan, it's literally hell, it's an oven.
When I'm touristing, not running or walking, I have to be most of the day in my hotel, because otherwise it's too warm.
So, first of all, before asking you about the route, etc., how do you do it to run in this climate?
The last few days I've been running in the night, like starting the day at 6 or 7 in the evening.
And running until 2 or 3 in the morning, but then, like, it's quite hard to sleep during the day, because it's very hot.
So, if I can find, like, a hotel, then, like, which is okay to check in, like, during the night, and then you can leave in the evening.
I could just sleep in, like, in the air conditioner.
But today it was not that hot, I mean, like, 38, I think.
So, I could start, like, 6 in the morning, and I stopped, like, at 1.
In the afternoon, so it was, like, the last two hours were quite warm, but it was still okay.
Yeah, and I guess you know the difference, you feel the difference in the...
It's the first interview I do in English in my life.
I guess you feel the difference in performance, of course, with this heat or not.
Yeah, yeah.
Because the wind is also hot.
Yeah.
It feels like...
It feels like someone is opening the door of the oven.
Yeah, the oven with a ventilator, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I've done the desert with my friend, Theo, who is the car assistant, so I could, like, have not the backpack with me.
So, I think it's, like, kind of balanced.
Like, the speed, like, the average speed is the same than before.
But you don't have the weight, so you have less.
Okay, okay, okay.
So, I guess, like, my heart rate is, like, lower than usual.
Yeah.
But because of the heat.
Yeah, the heat is, like, higher, so it's, like, kind of so-so.
Because Mathieu, he's carrying a backpack, unlike the other world runners that normally carry, they push a strolling cart.
Why do you have the backpack instead of the cart?
I like the way of being free to go anywhere and go on the trail.
And I also don't like to worry about something that I pack if I want to visit some stuff.
So, I like the...
I mean...
I mean, for me, this journey is about freedom, and I like the freedom that gives you the backpack.
But for some sections, like the one I just did, I think it's stupid to have, like, a backpack.
It's better, like, just to carry water and push it, because it's, like, flat and straight.
I had, like, 450 kilometers just straight line.
Like, no turn.
Like, two weeks almost.
Okay, let's talk about your route.
So, you started in Bologna.
And how did you arrive here, where you are now?
I think I took quite the same route than you.
So, like, basically, like, Slovenia, Croatia, Bosnia, Montenegro.
But you entered from North Macedonia instead of Greece?
No, no, I entered...
I went through Florina, which is, like, the full northwest of Greece.
Okay.
So, I went until, like, the coast, until...
Like, I left the coast to reach Tirana, in Albania.
And then, like, went straight east to Greece and then Turkey.
I entered Turkey, not Istanbul.
I went down, Chana Kale.
I took the ferry, like, a bit southern than you.
And then, I did some detour in Turkey to, like, do some hiking trails and see friends in Ankara.
And then, I joined the Black Sea coast a bit later.
And then, yeah, Georgia, quite same.
And then, after Georgia, I entered Russia.
I crossed it until Kazakhstan, then from Kazakhstan to here.
What was your experience in the Kazakh and Uzbekistan border?
Because it's not open.
So, what did you do there?
So, once I reached the...
Oh, you mean Kazakh-Uzbekistan.
But even, like, Russian-Kazakh was already...
Okay, this was already close.
Okay, explaining, explaining.
Like, two borders close.
Like, the first from Russia to Kazakhstan, when I reached it, I mean, it was open, but not with the electronic visa I applied for.
You can cross it, but just with the three-day visa, which is, like, the three-day transit visa, which was not enough for me to cross, like, the 800 kilometers.
So, once I reached the border, I turned back by, like, hitchhiking, bus, train until Tbilisi, where I flew to Atiraou, which is, like, Kazakhstan.
And then, took a taxi from Atiraou to...
To the border, where I start my run, like, the same place, but, like, other side of the border.
And between Kazakhstan and Uzbekistan was closed as well.
So, I turned back to Benin, where I took a train, which was, like, quite chaotic because, like, it was super hot.
Like, passport control in the night.
You have to stay awake until five in the morning.
Train with no air conditioning?
No air conditioning.
And how many hours?
I think it's, like, small places like this on the sofa, and you're, like...
Like, five people in the same, like, very small place.
And, like, when people are walking in the wagon, like, it's just, like, pushing you to just go through.
Then, like, in the morning, people selling dry fish in the...
Dry fish, yeah.
So, it's, you know, quite...
I was, like, very exhausted.
Was the worst part of the trip, maybe?
Almost.
I mean...
We'll talk about later, about the worst part, yes.
So, I mean, I did, like, 24 hours non-stop running to get that train.
24 hours?
Not...
Like, I did, like, I think it was, like, 10 hours, maybe, of running.
And then went back.
And because I started, like, early morning, I couldn't sleep before the train, because I was at the station.
There were, like, many people and waiting, just waiting for the train.
So, I almost didn't sleep for, like, yeah, two days.
Wow.
So, there, I was, like, so, so exhausted.
And then you ran to here, and that was the last thing.
And what's...
How many days you've been in the road in total?
So, it's, like, 208 days today.
And today, I just passed the 7,000 kilometers mark.
Bravo.
Yeah.
So, you have 40 days less than me, but 500 kilometers more than me.
Oh, 500.
Okay.
More or less.
How was the...
What's your average in the running days?
I'm running, like, between 40 and 50 kilometers a day.
I think, like, the average, including the day off...
It's, like, 35 something, some 30, so...
So, running, like, I walk a lot, I think, but running is more demanding to the body.
So, I think you are very strong.
What's your background in the running thing?
Like, I guess it's not your first run, of course.
I started with triathlon when I was a teenager.
Decathlon?
Triathlon.
Triathlon, okay.
Swimming, cycling, running.
So, I did, like...
Just when I could register, because I was too young for doing Ironman.
But when I was, like, old enough, I just started, like, doing Ironman.
And I fell in love with the very long distance things.
Then I stopped triathlon, and I went to just running, like, ultra trail and ultra marathon things.
And I went, like, from 100K to, like, 200, 100 miles, 200 miles, 500K, 1000 miles.
1000.
Yeah, I, like, I did, like, FKT, which is, like, faster snow time things.
And, like, for trails in France, I've done more than 1000 kilometers, like, and, yeah, like, 1300, 1000.
So, what's your FKT now?
Which ones do you hold?
So, I have, I've got kind of a other goal, goal life.
Yes.
Apart doing this world tour is to get the record of the 10 longest trail.
Uh, in France.
I've got two of them already.
Uh-huh.
Which ones?
It's, like, JR3 and JR4.
So, one is, like, following the biggest river in France, which is called La Loire.
Uh-huh.
And the other one is, like, crossing, like, Massif Central, like, middle of France, mountain range until, like, the Alps.
Okay.
So, yeah, you're a beast.
Yes.
And then I did, like, I did my personal best in marathon in Barcelona, actually.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
Wow, wow, wow.
Why?
Why are you doing this?
I guess it's obvious, but.
I think I like traveling.
I like the adventure.
I like challenging myself.
I've done a kind of big journey, like, four, five years ago.
But it was, like, just hitchhiking, but just going around the world.
And I missed that.
So, I wanted to go on a trip again.
But I still wanted to run.
Because I'll.
I love so much running.
So, like, kind of.
How did you discover the World Runners Association?
So, yeah.
Then, like, my goal was to start from kind of Marco Polo way, like, starting from Venice
and until, like, Xi'an or Beijing.
And then I just, like, randomly found, like, World Runners Association.
But maybe three weeks before leaving.
Ah, wow.
So, I changed, like, when I.
Amazing.
I've been preparing this for three weeks.
Two years.
And you three weeks before.
No, but I was planning to go to China anyway.
But when I saw that, I was like, no, I didn't know that.
So, maybe I learned this 10 days before Christmas.
And once it was Christmas, I told my family, maybe I won't go just for, like, 10 months.
But maybe it's going to be, like, more than two years.
Before starting this, I guess you didn't have an ordinary life, right?
Yeah.
You were, like, nomad.
You told me before.
Yeah.
So, I've been living in a van, like, for five years.
Walking in the wintertime in ski resorts.
And just enjoying summertime in the van.
Who's taking care of the van now?
No.
No one?
I mean, it's, like, it's parked in my parents' home.
Okay.
So, they took it sometime to.
No, but I know that today the battery is low.
So, no one is, like, taking care of it.
I had the same.
I had the same issue.
They heard it.
I had the same issue and I had to.
But luckily, my vehicle broke and I had to turn it, like, turn it into a coupe just before starting.
I will see this later.
It's, like, yeah.
What are your next steps from here?
So, the total route.
Yeah.
Your plan right now, at least.
So, the next step is to survive the summertime in Uzbekistan.
Then reach the, like, the Pamir mountain.
So, you enter Tajikistan, right?
Enter Tajikistan, then went north to Uzbekistan again, just for, like, small part.
And then Kyrgyzstan, then Kazakhstan again, to enter China, like, northwest, in the Xinjiang.
And then cross the whole China until the Pacific Ocean to reach, like, the, to make the ocean, ocean things.
Okay, stop here.
So, China has this 30 days.
Yeah.
Unless you have a special visa, which is very hard to obtain.
No.
You have this 30 days.
How are you going to cross China?
So, every 30 days, I'm going to get out of the country and, like, go out, go in, and start
where I stop each time.
So, like, the first time, I probably go back to Kazakhstan, to Almaty.
And then the next time, I've, like, I don't know, still, like, Thailand, Vietnam.
I think you can even take train.
Hong Kong, I think, is the cheapest.
Maybe.
But I would like to not take too many planes.
So, I've heard that you can take train from China to, like, Vietnam.
Yeah.
Vietnam, Thailand, even.
So, it's, like, a super high-speed train, so.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know.
I will see this.
So, it's, like, every day, step by step.
You will reach the Pacific Ocean in Beijing, more or less?
Yeah.
And after that?
After that, I go to Australia to cross it from Indian Ocean to Pacific Ocean.
From Perth to Sydney.
Okay.
And then to South America.
So, same, like, from Pacific Ocean to Atlantic Ocean.
I think I'm going to start in Santiago, in Chile.
Okay.
Or, like, more or less.
And reach, like, Buenos Aires in Argentina.
And then I'm not sure about how many kilometers I'm going to have to complete the 26,000 things
of the WRA.
And maybe I'll keep going along the coast.
Uruguay, Brazil, maybe.
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
And then your last leg of the journey in Europe.
Yeah.
So, on your first leg of the journey in Europe, do you know where you're going to start?
So, yeah.
I have to join the Atlantic Ocean to the Bologna.
And there is, like, one of the...one of the ten longest trails in France.
It's part of, like...yeah.
It's, like, starting from the Atlantic Ocean and crossing France, like, from west to Italy actually.
So maybe I'm going to try this FKG on the way.
Okay.
That would be epic.
Yeah.
I will see.
What is your expected time of Arab?
of arrival like in total what how much time do you think it will take um in three days i will
reach like the seven months thing and i've just reached like seven thousand so i guess it's like
one thousand for one month so it should be like 26 months but i think this winter time is like
gonna be quite hard so i might have some rest in thailand for like two weeks or maybe three weeks
even if it's like so yeah i think my first goal for this year is to reach the 10 000 kilometers
in one year maybe same for next year so i expected to be back before 20 28 summertime i would like to
so it's like two two years and a half are you tired i am it depends like today it's fine but
i have some days it's like let's say generally
tired you know uh i think less than the beginning like it was okay while i was entering in turkey was
quite difficult i was like yeah your body's more used to the long days and running i think i
kind of found my limit where it's like now it's too much for it's not the body it's more like the
the mind like when you wake up in the morning and you don't want to run anymore yeah it's like not
good sign so i tried to to
to rest every time i feel i'm bored with this thing yeah yeah i'm tired like almost so it's
more like mentally tired than yeah missing home yeah not didn't miss home much not yet it's fine
yeah i've been away from home like for two years i mean i've been yeah traveling like
i've been quite alone for many years now so i think i can yeah i can manage this did you have
any injury like
i kind of it's starting yeah like maybe the desert because i can just make this is like
taking me slowly slowly um yeah i got some the shoulder is a bit painful i guess it's because
my backpack should be very tight for like not moving while running so maybe it's because of that
for the shoulder and i've got some pain under the the feet like during like since maybe three weeks
now so i messaged every day it's like going better after massage but then like i run again
are you worried about this like really worried or are you fine i i know i would be yeah i know i
would be yeah but i know that when i'm walking it's like i feel that i'm racing like when i do
like a full run day it's like painful the day after and then i can work like the full day and
then the day after it's like way way better so i think i can recover for it but uh i'm worried
because it could like uh take the the way of doing my thing like like uh no no of course that's the
thing like uh prevent you from running yeah yeah or so fast yeah and you are sharing your journey
if i'm not mistaken only in strada basically i don't have instagram account yeah
and it's not like you shared like you you put like a text every day more or less in french
yeah and then some pictures uh yeah not every day not every day lazy lazy sometimes
yeah i try to explain sometimes when it's like something um yeah i i try to read your comments
and people are asking for more you want more but yeah you don't feel like you're
exhausted i've got a camera with me and i'm filming quite uh all my journey but i like the
idea of keeping everything for myself for now and once i'll be back i know a movie maker and he's
going he's going to do like a movie on youtube i mean i don't know about youtube but he's going to
make a video at the end and it's going to be like i don't know one hour video i prefer this like
i prefer to take uh i don't take attention of people for like one hour
instead of a little bit of every day yeah i don't know it's i guess i'm the opposite
yeah i want to do a documentary also but whatever um so yeah people ask for more
what do your parents say uh they ask first of all how old are you uh i am 30 since like one
month now 30. and you were born in the north of france you said yeah okay so what do your parents
so my parents they they've so they they collect all the video because my camera is like maximum
uh storage so i said i sent them like they have the vip footage yeah okay they've got everything
it's like um yeah it's good way for me to not have to say like everything i'm doing and just
they have like the yeah so and i mean that i've i've been traveling for many years so
i guess they used to i mean they know i'm i'm getting bored if they're like asking me all the
time or where is it so when i walk i can do a lot of things in with my hands because i don't have
trekking poles and yeah oh yeah that's strange actually because it helped even running it helped
me so much yeah if i had to do a lot of uphills and downhills all the time i i would take it in
in nepal i would take i probably would buy them but since now i'm like doing like a lot of things
so much so so there i have the the hands quite free so i use the phone a lot but running it's
uh different you have to be with yourself and your your music or your podcast or whatever so
does it get like mentally tiring is it that the problem the all the hours that you're alone or i
i guess it's like less hours in the day than you i run like five to six hours every day okay yeah
less than you but maybe it's a bit harder i mean when when you're running you'll you always feel
that please stop and walk and so that the battle is more like keep running and don't walk um but i
like the the idea of this battle like the every you like it yeah i mean it's not it's a bit painful
the world runs association says that you have to at least
run 50 percent yeah do you keep track of that or you are sure that you are running 50 more i think
i have no idea how many percent i i run and i don't think they can actually check it but
i think they just trust you and but that's why also sometimes i'm a bit worried about the my my
average speed so i'm like oh this is too slow today that could be like considered as walking so
let's run faster so
i think i would say like i'm running 60 70 percent of time when it's flat when it's like
mountain i'm walking uphill and running downhill but that's like there is no other way
i think i'm like compared to other world runners i'm more using hiking trails than than them
because they're like the buggies they have to stay on the road i like to go on trail
so i guess that's a bit different and even like doing two days and a half you know you're not going to make it this much
ultra trail you're like some like for 200 miles 500 kilometers is considered like ultra trail
running races but most of people they like work all the work all the time almost so
i'm i feel more it's like doing that things by foot and then working running it's quite same
actually okay matthew walk me through your backpack because i'm very curious yeah that's
the way you do when it's like minimalist backpack because everything is tight and small then at the
end of the day you throw everything on the floor yeah so that's like basically my mattress very
small yeah my backpack is that one that's like 32 liters and i've got like extra pack in front
so i can put like my camera my poncho and some okay can you put the backpacks so we can see
but this has a lot of pockets in the
front i guess i've got like this like running thing and then it's like water there and then
this thing is like basically clipping is it comfortable it's very comfortable and then you
can tight it even more here here and then i've got this in front of me and i've got like like
train bags right back jacket this is my tent which is not well
packed now very small should be like smaller even this is the shipping bag
how many degrees
comfort five uh zero or minus zero comfort six and comfort six zero yeah okay and that's like
you have another no that was just like for the for the desert joining me okay yeah and this is like
also like anti-uv cloth and that's it the sandals yeah and then some electronics no i guess yeah
i've got some electronics there some clothes on me so yeah very many movies you say this is
nine kilos yeah i think yeah eight more eight kilos now okay okay and these are the shoes how
many kilometers you say so this is like 1000 kilometers not bad i've got like i've bought
those new things because those were like super super flat already and i never changed that
yeah i needed it for my
four feet okay so quick questions what was your favorite country in this in this trip
the one you had the best time i had a very warm welcome in croatia um like once i you
crossed the istria peninsula actually i think like from trieste to yes i i passed it i didn't go
yeah you went straight and i followed there like a hiking trail okay and i did it in one day so it
was like super super long day i think i had like 56 kilometers and like almost 3000 elevation
so when i reached like the other side it was like night and uh i went out of the forest and there
were like one farmer he just stopped me asked me some some questions we were just like chatting
together
and he asked me my uh my uh my name on facebook and the day the day after i saw it was like
journalist and i saw like there were like some newspapers and then like the the tv contacted me
so i went to tv in croatia and people could recognize me in the street so it was like very
very nice and okay yeah it was it was nice feeling to be there i feel very supportive supported in
greece in croatia
and turkey i i love this country so much and i had like last time i spent six months there
and really loved it but this time was a bit different because of the kangals the lovely
kangals so it was yeah i think it's the dogs yeah the dogs yeah the big dogs in church that's why i
well let's talk about the dogs later worst country or the country you enjoyed the least
um i don't know uzbekistan has been quite hard since like i've been we i've been in the desert
just like the last couple of days so yeah it was hard and uh i had a fine to pay two days ago
so it didn't help but i i like everywhere it's bosnian just i've been there just one
day i didn't like it so much bosnia there was a little light very quick favorite
food which country favorite food georgia have like nice georgia worst food worst food
worst food i don't know how to say for me it was croatia yeah yeah croatia is not that great
yeah i like the burek it's like fine yeah fine quick yeah easy to take away yeah yeah i don't
know okay um best people the best people in turkey definitely yeah worst people worst people
uh maybe georgia uh yeah okay there some of them are very rude yeah some of them are very
hospitalized to me yeah yeah yeah okay best um trails or best roads or where you have these
problems i think it's like the
way you enjoy it really depends on your mind so sometimes it's very i enjoy it a lot like i
i love so much the the black sea coast whereas it was just like you did it it was like highway
on the side but um i like the fig yoli which was in turkey it was like hiking trail and
nice i i saw some canyon and the view was nice but i was a bit tired at this time so i didn't i'd
enjoy that much worst roads or worst trails like the ones that you had more problems for me for
example it was italy because the there is no yeah yeah yeah i think i wasn't that much focused at
this time because it was the beginning i was just like exciting and but yeah i think yeah
okay and lastly best moment like like that moment only one moment
only one moment
at the start the start yeah did you start alone um i start alone and during the night because i missed
my my bus to go to bologna so then i reached bologna it was like seven in the evening but
it was winter time so it was like dark already since long time but there was like a girl singing
in the square where i've studied and it was like yeah i feel
i feel yeah i felt very nice there because i was like alone i wanted to start alone
kind of uh hidden and uh just myself and and starting touching the fountain where i started
and like people around around me they couldn't know what i was like studying i i like this
feeling okay um worst moment the worst moment was the congress in turkey um in turkey yeah because
yeah when we spoke yeah because we spoke you had a very big problem in greece yeah with six
race dogs that yeah they almost eat you alive yeah but you had the worst time in turkey okay explain
that i have quite the same situation and with bigger dogs but they were shepherd dogs or shepherd
dogs yeah this time was shepherd dogs but like close to like hankara or where was it uh it was
in anatolia definitely i couldn't remember okay where it was yeah i think just just before ankara
yeah like western western of ankara like just before ankara yeah like western western of ankara like
uh kutaya between kutaya and ankara and yeah it was yeah i think i they they attacked me for like
maybe one hour one hour yeah and i was with the sticks the paper spray and then you use the
pepper spray i used no i didn't use this time because i was trying to like beat them with the
stick i could you hit them with this thing no i was like like this sometimes okay if you like do
this they're like know that you're fighting but i think they'll they they stop the
the fight actually because some of some of like two of them they tried to jump on me like uh so they
were like just around me and one jump on me there and then i turned then he was there and then it
was like ready fight for almost one hour so it was but they didn't bite you they know they never bite
me so one hour they wanted you to get out from there but you couldn't because you were surrounded
i walked like i walked maybe three kilometers uh when when the like yeah i was like three kilometers
and i was like okay i'm gonna start fighting so it wasn't like the at the beginning the
ships were like far away i could see them but then i saw the dogs coming to me uh the shepherd was
like they didn't care much yeah sometimes they're yelling but then it's like very windy and the dogs
they come here and then you move and then you're like you don't see even the sheep anymore yeah
you work like for half an hour like two kilometers you're like there's like nothing to protect anymore
and yeah and sometimes i think they're like
because for them like you you go through the village and like you're running and then like
what happened and then they want to change and then like uh yeah i think first they are scared
and then then then they're like okay let's fight now so well so you are very relieved now since
at the end of georgia because you didn't fight did you find dogs in russia or not uh there is no dog
okay okay even in georgia was was still okay like i guess i i went there just before the shepherds
i had i had a bad time and i will spend you later yeah well matt very thank you very much
very good luck in your journey maybe we meet again i don't know
thank you very much and follow him on strada whatever i don't know thanks